for me it's like i like seeing other
people achieve things they didn't think
was possible
um i like i like having people believe
in things that are bigger than
themselves
you know i look back at own was a
complete
you know was as a problem you know when
i was running xm it was a startup
no one thought we ever could get people
to pay for radio and we did
um and when we built that company it was
the same way and then all the radio
stations and all the country stuff they
were all like
you can't go at 23 to move to seattle
and be this you can't do
and so a lot of my pathology in my life
had been you can't you can't you can't
you can't you can't and what i realized
was i was proving something to myself
but then what i actually realized that
the joy came from actually watching
other people
see things that they can't see having
them believe
in the fact that we could do this and
believe in the fact that we
were going to do this and then seeing
that happen
was like more fulfilling to me than
anything else i believe
that each and every one of us has the
power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today we have the very inspirational
eric logan on the podcast
he is the ceo of the world surf league
formerly president
of the own network and vice president of
harpo studios when oprah was in chicago
the way he looks at business and life
is so much beyond just sort of maybe the
quintessential
like the way you'd think of a a ceo or a
businessman being about like numbers
and go go go i mean there's go and
there's numbers but
before that there's the mindset of
what it is that you want to accomplish
and then
the true and utter belief needed
to make it happen like there's a
difference between
wanting to do something thinking about
doing something and truly believing like
down through your bones that something
is going to
happen and and work and be successful
and so eric is a great storyteller he's
totally open he's really funny um
and uh and has taken on this really cool
new job of being ceo of the world surf
league which is such a transition so i
of course
wanted to know all about how you go from
being the president of own network to
running a surf league so uh we're gonna
hear
today all about his uh what he would
call church
how did an oklahoma boy fall in love
with surfing
doesn't seem to go together it doesn't
yeah you don't it's not it's not a
poster you have in your house
when you grow up of like you know you
have basketball players you don't have
like surf people
that's in there um it's an interesting
story so when i moved to los
angeles to run the network for oprah i
had moved to manhattan beach
and lived in manhattan beach with my two
daughters
and ultimately at a certain point you
just kind of cave to the
whole environment that happens and so i
get as a joke
my a wetsuit as a joke now mind you grew
up in oklahoma
had never properly learned how to swim i
was afraid of the water
afraid of the sharks afraid of
everything that goes in there
and so i got a wetsuit it's a joke it's
okay whatever so i put this wetsuit on
and i wander out into the ocean and it
was the most
bizarre comforting and even
you know powerful surrendering feeling
i'd ever had in my life
because you felt insulated and protected
because you could feel the water but it
wasn't cold
it was just like really sort of so no
board yet just the suit you're just
talking about the relationship with the
suit and the feeling
me and the relationship with the lover
wow and
and so then you look around and you see
okay there's these people that are like
on boards and boogie boards
so i'm like okay i got an idea so i'll
go buy a boogie board now mind you i'm
41 at the time
okay 41 years old so most people who are
boogie boarding
are under the age of seven yep that's
what i've seen
so i i say this is gonna be really
interesting so i go grab a boogie board
and all of a sudden i'm having fun
with a bunch of rando seven
eight-year-olds in manhattan beach
you can imagine the looks from the
parents
looking at this grown man now boogie
boarding on the beach with all of this
curiosity yeah concern that's right
they're googling my name
on like predator websites that's right
right they're like
so um so i look up i i get back i go
all right so i really need to try
surfing so i take one surf lesson
from a guy who i'm still a friend with
and i still surf with to this day
really his name is taylor hine it was
just a random thing on camp surf
and camp surf what's that it's a it was
just you
type it surf lessons in google is the
first thing that popped up and it was
this little local surf company
in south bay here in california and he
shows up
by the way 15 minutes late right out of
central casting
sunglasses hat on backwards completely
ripped
six out six pack attached the whole
thing so he was california on time
a hundred percent i mean he did not
think he was late whatsoever
so i took my first lesson jumped up on
and he put me on a huge thing we called
barn doors they're like gigantic boards
that like anybody could stand up on
it caught my first wave it literally
changed my life it was
you felt you know it was like what was
this feeling that i had
got out of the water drove to a surf uh
shop
and bought my first board and then as we
like to say um
you know as a fan of the matrix you
follow the white rabbit took the red
pill and down the rabbit hole i go
and then nowhere on the sort of vision
board of my life did i ever think
it would take me traveling the world
meeting all these people
and now i get to a place where i'm you
know the ceo of the world surf league
it's kind of crazy so full circle so
it's yeah
i don't even know where in the circle
i'm at if it's full or if i'm like
halfway through i don't even know where
i'm at on the circle but it's pretty
interesting journey time and space don't
really matter
i mean if you like the matrix then
you're probably into a little esoteric
thinking yourself
um what you you said it's the rat
you know it's the it's the red pill what
where did that go what happened next
so what happened to me on my journey
into the ocean
was more of a spiritual transformation
for my life
and what was so interesting for me was
that you know prior to that point in
time for the past four years before that
i was
you know the president of harpo so i was
running the oprah winfrey show for oprah
we were syndicating the show
uh we started the cable network um it
owned out here in los angeles but i was
still living in chicago with the studio
and we hadn't really shut down the
company yet we were shutting down harpo
so
may 25th 2011 we did it so i've been
around obviously
at i would consider one of the highest
levels in terms of like enlightenment
spirituality and just being in her
presence it's like
i don't know i mean if there's a higher
vibration i mean super soul sunday sort
of
really opened me up it was a beautiful
it's a beautiful thing and
and and for me it was like okay i'm
running the company
i understand it i'm around it i see all
the people in the sphere
it connected with me but it never really
like
moved me like it moves most people
and what was interesting was as i
started finding all these lessons that
was happening to me in the ocean and i
was making i was connecting these dots i
was having all these aha moments
it'd be like i'm stuck on the inside
getting pummeled and you learn about
surrender stop fighting the ocean and go
on all these things and so there was
there was one conversation in particular
where when i came back from a trip
i had this really scary moment you know
on a reef in fiji
and i was telling oprah about it and she
literally was just smiling and i talked
for like 20 minutes and she said
you have found your spiritual calling
like and so
all of our conversations about surfing
were about the linkages
about the metaphors of ocean tides
currents life love everything
analogy for life and it just and
from that it it opened me up in a way
that i'd never been opened up before and
here i was sitting next to her for many
many years but surfing was the thing
that i never knew i wanted to do
it was a passion i never knew i thought
i'd have and it
boom it clicked everywhere so much so
there's a great there's a fun there's a
fun little anecdotal story about that
that
every morning no matter what the
conditions were i get up at dawn
i drive to the beach and i'm in the
ocean as soon as it's like this morning
as soon as the light's up i'm out on the
water so there was a conference call one
morning
that she had called she was back east
and it was like seven or eight here or
whatever it was
and oprah would always refer to the
ocean when i go out as my
church she'd be like that is your
sanctuary so there's a call and i think
we're on with like the presidents of all
these other people there's all these
united states whatever she's on that's a
funny story too but
there's okay you know there's she was on
this call and
and and uh i think my co was on the call
and i get out and my phone is like blown
up it's like where are you
you know oprah's looking for you yeah
and then and all of a sudden they're
like yeah she goes don't worry about i
just told him you're a church you'd be
out at 8 30.
and she just knew and she just knew not
to call me and still to this day every
so often she'll just send me a nice
little text
house church this morning and i'll be
like it's beautiful and
it turned out to be a gorgeous thing so
that was uh that's how the
fusion of this
thing and i talk about it a lot it's
like you just never know what is the one
thing that just
opens you up and lights you up and it
lit me up
did you feel like you had to make some
changes as you started surfing was there
like some epiphany some
sort of like um did it jar your life in
any way as you sort of
sort of went to church regularly well it
depends because church service takes on
many forms
sometimes it's really big i can scare
you
um you know it it
it actually changed me in a way
that it reminds me that there are things
in life that are much bigger than you
you know i the single biggest thing i
say to myself about the ocean is that it
reminds me that there are things
beyond yourself we are just a small
piece of a much larger mosaic of life
and
when you sit out into an ocean and
forget that there's a wave it is v you
feel very small
and it and it grounds you and so to me
it's a grounding mechanism
you know in my busy life it is how i
connect with myself
and it's how i always stay centered and
grounded so that
to me is the reoccurring thing that that
comes to me
um my frustration my my desire
my my work everything comes intersects
into that place
and a good day and a bad day so you know
what
you can't actually dictate
to the ocean what you'd want to do as a
driver in your career you know you were
in control
of a car you know the track wasn't
moving
you you know if you missed your mark
that that's on you
with a wave the wave is going to do what
the wave is going to do so you are
purely having to surrender and get into
a flow state if you want to do what you
want to do
and i think that that metaphor through
life and business is just such a good
one to keep in mind and so surfing for
me helps remind me of that
what has um been the hardest thing
that you've had to surrender to in that
lesson
my ego that's a lot of work yeah
and it's a it's an hourly struggle
sometimes minutes struggle it's hard
um and so the thing for me
is trusting the universe
and trusting you know flow and and
learning
that things are you know things that are
happening to you
are always happening for you somebody we
both know
says that um and it's a hard lesson to
learn and i think that
you know i try to find things in my life
that can always reaffirm that in my
business life
and my personal life with my daughters
um and certainly when
i have a spare time to go for a pe i i
only have to be in the ocean for five or
ten minutes
i don't need to be out there all day i
just need to be out there and it just
reconnects me and it regrounds me and
i'm good
it's like your meditation too it's a
thousand church or your meditation
it's their grounding it's resetting it's
it can take on whatever modality to
achieve it that you want
um that you want being from oklahoma
seems pretty
classic christian is that the upbringing
you had
so i interestingly i was raised more
protestant
okay um i was very lost had a very
interesting troubled childhood with my
parents too too
um sixth grade a friend of mine took me
to
catholic mass for the first time okay
and
i fell in love with it i fell in love
with the catholic church and so i just
stopped going to
a protestant church and started going to
a catholic church
and i realized later that it was the
structure
of catholicism that i loved so i hustled
i got confirmed i
did everything and i converted to become
a catholic and so i did that through
sixth grade through high school through
a little bit of college started working
and then i just sort of wandered off and
i would say you know today
you know i i believe in higher callings
i believe in higher
spirituality i believe in higher
connection but i'm not a practicing
you know catholic today um but i wasn't
really
raised with the more like very rigid
dogmatic view that
some people would think i mean
oklahoma's got an identity crisis as a
state
does it yeah well you're not the south
you're not the north oh that's right
yeah so it's not the midwest i mean
you're a midwest girl
i am and do you what do you can so what
do you consider it
or does it just sort of like is it a
swing vote you know you just it's a
swing vote
so if you if if you and i are out at the
dinner and you were saying you're from
the midwest i would say i'm from the
midwest too and i would declare oklahoma
in the midwest
if i'm out with somebody else and
they're like they're from alabama and
they're from the south i'm like hey
we're the south too
so we're very utopian that way wow they
refer to it as the switzerland
they totally hundred percent that's
okies are a funny breed
what uh i mean especially being exposed
to oprah for so long and
what were some of those things you know
what were some gems that you learned
from her yeah so the thing that i
one of the single biggest lessons that
i've taken from her that i use today
at the world surf league um is the value
of intention
and she talks often about making sure
that every conversation every situation
you do
every show had an intention and so much
so like
every i mean decade i work for and
picks up the phone it would be what's
the intention of this call
really 100 and if you don't understand
what
is actually meant by the statement or
question it can be very off-putting yeah
you know people like
if i you know imagine me just roll up
and hey what's the intention in this
interview you'd be like excuse me
versus yeah i can see that it reverses
it's sort of like i just want to make
sure we're aligned so i can hear you the
right way
and and oftentimes in life and in
business
that i have found is like you've been a
part of these conversations we all have
where
like 20 minutes into a meeting you have
this like thought bubble like
what is happening why am i talking to
you how
who who are you i mean you may have that
moment here shortly i was thinking
you might have that moment she knows
nothing about surfing
oh no you know more than you think but
but i think but the lesson of that is
like always returning to the intention
and then
you know you have certainly with the
network we went through a very well
documented phase of struggle
and in order to turn the network around
with her name on the door
everything that we did we had to look
back and we started
with the question of like what was the
intention of that show what was the
intention of this and then what we do
because then you have results or
whatever it is you're able to look
and understand it along the way so that
connects to this other piece where we
was always talking about what's what are
the lessons that you get
you know the lessons along the way and
um you know
the world comes to us in a series of
lessons they're small
and they get louder then they get bigger
because you're not listening because
you're not listening
and so if you understand intention and
then you see the lessons along the way
and once you get those lessons
they stop happening and so that sort of
meant so that
is a lot of the conversations that we'd
have
you know it's not like you know we're
not i'm not whipping out a p l
and being like all right here's where we
are in the sub fees and here's the ad
revenue and the cpms and the cash flows
she certainly is into that but we spent
a lot of time
she and i and a lot of time with our
creative team focusing on these sort of
spaces which
you know honestly danica change changed
me how i run companies i've been running
companies most of my life it changed
forever how i run it i run the world
surf league the same way
i want to get back to the ego go ahead
let's do it
i just think it's a thing i think it's a
especially with
men but it just comes off in a more
masculine way it's just a little more
aggressive at times it's a little more
a little less encouraged to get in touch
with your feelings yeah um
oh that have you ever cried out there in
the ocean do you cry ever
quite a lot actually really yeah yeah
thank you for admitting that yeah um
but i just think i don't know it maybe
you can tell me your perspective but
on sort of where we're at as a culture
and the world right now but i feel like
dissolving the ego is of the utmost
importance
in what's going on in the world how do
you feel about all that
well i think at the end first of all
everybody has to acknowledge
that you have one or a healthy ego maybe
a little caveat here a healthy
healthy relationship with the ego yeah i
think i think that's the second part i
think the first part is that there are
people
who i've come across i'm sure you have
too it's like i don't have an ego
and it's like okay don't you understand
by virtue of the fact of the statement
you do
um and and understanding
hearing your ego speak to me has been
one that
you know this for me has been the
hardest lesson for me to get
because often times when you're either
thrust in the media
or you're built up on a pedestal or
you're told that you are
something you a believe it and then you
perpetuate the story yourself
and then you use that as your own
self-validation and then you as a person
use that as a way to justify things
either good behaviors or bad behaviors
that you want to do
and so that is how at times it manifests
itself inside of me
i think for all of us to be able to
understand how your ego
manifests inside of yourself can
dramatically change how the world sees
you
and and and i think that we have a lot
of factors i've got teenage daughters
so i see this like playing out in front
of my eyes
on the weeks that i have my girls i i
see them it's
it's all about appearance and the social
media and how it looks and all these
sort of things
and again the way i interpret that
that's all about
feeding the ego monster because it's all
about that self validation how many
likes do you have and you have this
and and of course it feels good of
course it feels great but it feels great
to who
to me i interpret that it feels good to
my ego and it's sort of like ah great
article
ah that feels good i think that
there is a a very real issue in terms of
people coming to terms with that the way
is being represented
you know in terms of the world today um
it's hard
and i don't have an answer for it
because i'm struggling with it with my
daughters
uh who are very much into this this
world and i see it
i see it from an interesting point of
view with with teenage girls and so
part of the reason why i cry a lot too
they keep me very humble oh my god
i think i made my dad cry a lot too um
maybe you can give me some tips
you have to go through the [ __ ] at the
end of the day i mean lessons have to be
learned the hardware is the hard way
sometimes
a lot of times um is there a check-in
is there a certain like is there certain
things that you've learned that help you
to
know when you're sort of more in that
ego space versus not
it comes to me when
something happens like damn why'd that
happen you know
so i drop a glass okay um
you know my daughter barks at me which
i've i've learned not to make that about
the ego because that's what 15 and 16
looks like so put that aside
um car almost pulls you almost sometimes
i have these like
either i hit my head i stubbed my toe
it's things like that
i can't find my car keys things like
that it's like
i i take it i look at those moments it's
a trigger for me and it's very hard and
i'm not very good at it but i
try to be like let's check in with
myself what's going on
just shut everything down just stop and
go okay
what's happening why'd that happen um
you know sometimes i look at this way
it's like i'm late
i'm running late i got to get someplace
and then
you get going and maybe there's a car
accident that happened
four blocks in front of you and the
universe
actually did that to you on purpose to
protect you that's the way i look at
these things i thought it was double
punishment you're late
and they made a car accident there so
they're like okay are we driving this
home enough that you need to be on time
or you can look at it um from a point of
view that
you know it it is actually working to
your benefit
the universe is working to your benefit
check in with yourself and so
it it's hard and and i sometimes i try
to be very aware that
when i get into the place where i feel
like i'm elevated and my energy is like
very very high and i'm vibrating very
high and i'm talking very fast and i'm
just going and going to get interesting
a little frantic and you're like okay
check in with yourself
slow down why is that happening um
that's to me how the ego starts to build
itself up around myself
what's the uh loudest most difficult
lesson that the universe has sent you
ooh probably losing
both my parents and um
and
there's so many unresolved issues you
know
with both of my parents from oklahoma
for a variety of reasons which you know
we don't need to do a legacy series of
your podcast you only have an hour
all of our issues come from childhood
yeah they all come from childhood
so and and it was like i'd always would
put off
the hard conversations i'd always put
off the forgiveness conversations i'd
always put off with my
you know i never i'd always put them off
you know
and just to keep the peace just to yeah
and it was just like
it is always it's like you can find 100
reasons not to do one thing
i can come up with a million reasons why
i don't want to call it somebody i can
come up
and it's like all right my mom is my
mom's in oklahoma my dad's here
they're divorced i've got to ah
i gotta call somebody i gotta do
something i don't have time to go back i
mean it there's always everybody needs
me
oprah needs me you know there's the
waves are pumping you know there's
right there's ocean needs me ocean needs
me danica needs you can't be late for
church yeah i can't believe
6 47 this morning i and so
it it losing my mother first
actually helped me start to address
issues with my dad
then my dad died shortly thereafter
coincidentally i mean they had been
divorced
and and and my brother and i both had
this conversation it was just like
okay and he and i started talking more
you know which hadn't really sort of
happened and so so i would say that it
is
it was don't put off the hard
conversations have the hard
conversations
you know do the work have the hard work
um
and that's a very personal one for me
and there's a hundred business ones i'm
sure i could come up with if i thought
about it but
i just the first thing it pops tomorrow
night obviously i mean i
only just met you but i get the sense
that
the work all stems from the spiritual
element it all stems from heart space it
all stems from intention it all stems
from
a deeper place than p l's and
making money and that just happens
naturally
by product yeah exactly how did that
though transfer
into work so i think that you said
obviously you learned the lesson from
your parents
passing but that means that you learned
a lesson and that doesn't stop at just
well my next set of parents i'm going to
treat you know what i mean like it goes
somewhere
yeah probably everywhere it goes
everywhere i mean i think it gives you
you know for me it really
i was already i was already because they
both had been
diagnosed so i knew that they were going
to get sick and i could because
that the realization of that journey is
happening of hospice and things of that
nature you're like okay i gotta start
getting my mind around that
um but look i mean i think age plays a
big part of it too
you know i mean you know ego when you're
20
you go when you're then when you get
into 40 it takes on different
coats it it changes it's not the same
it means different things at different
points in your life
and um i would say that
the intersection of my personal life my
professional life
especially when my first daughter was
born became one of the same and actually
was different prior to that i mean i've
been working professionally since i was
15.
you know flunked out of college barely
graduated high school worked all
through my life and so my then you were
a dj for a while yeah and i was and so
that's all i knew
chuck the duck chucker trucker chuck the
duck yeah
that's when i met scott by the way when
i was a mascot fyi a friend of mine
we can do that in a minute but it was it
was so wrapped up in my identity
of like who i was and what i did
and and my ego would be like you have to
portray yourself as something that
you're not you know and it was like
i was a very insecure you know not
successful student
you know it was terrible at sports and
athletics but yet oh i'm a dj i'm on the
television now
you know i'm i changed my last name so
logan's not like my real last name
i created this whole persona of a person
that i wanted to be
that's not who i really was as a kid and
at a certain point those two parallel
lines of your personal life and your
professional life
ultimately fuse together and you
actually become
a more deeper loving open person when
you actually see the symbiotic nature of
both of them
becoming one that was the struggle for
most of my 30s and it wasn't
really until i had my second daughter
and then i hit my 40s and i really
realized it came together
and maybe some help with oprah who knows
i feel like we're seeing this shift in
society
i i it makes me really think about uh
the face of television like when you
look at something
like what oprah has done and that you
helped her create helped
fulfill her vision be part of that um
you know that sort of a network changes
the landscape of
content did you guys feel like that
there was many times we didn't you know
it was you know we started the network
when we launched in 2011 on january 1st
with the idea that we were going to take
the fundamental pieces of what made the
oprah show successful
and do that as a cable network makes
sense seems like a good idea
and what we realized was that we
did not appropriately think about the
audience that was
sitting there for pay cable because she
had a platform at that
point in time for 24 years on free
broadcast air and she
always was on at four o'clock everywhere
in the country except for one market by
the way
oh arizona oklahoma no no no chicago
chicago chicago yeah she she was on in
the morning in chicago it was the only
market
in america that the oprah show was not
on at four o'clock and it was because
that's where she got her that's when it
first started when she was on wls
and she did not want those viewers to
have to move
so that was when we would do all the
syndication deals was like that yep but
chicago at 11.
uh just a more little cocktail trivia um
but when we started the network we we
thought a lot about
from an intentional point of view we
take the elements of the show but it
didn't connect with the audience didn't
connect with the viewers
um which was what like if you were to
say like we really focused on these
things
health wellness that didn't register and
here's why
the the landscape of cable network
and really is different than broadcast
and it
get core word broadcast broad so if you
watch abc from top to bottom
you know it's everything from good
morning america to
soap operas to talk shows to
drama it's this broadcast right if you
think about cable networks
they're very very narrow so the analogy
i use when i was running the network was
look broadcasts are a mile wide and a
foot deep
successful cable networks are an inch
wide and five miles deep
cnn boom cnbc boom so what we were
trying to do with the beginning parts of
the network
this is where it was broad so we
narrowed it down and
we focused on really trying to
fulfill a void that we identified that
what
what cable and what certainly the united
states hadn't seen
are powerful images of african-american
women
portrayed in in in the appropriate way
and
um you know we would always say that you
know images matter
and she would drill that into our head
and so we always had to make sure we
were
putting the aspirational and the proper
images and having the real conversations
that were happening and the show that
sort of broke it through for us was a
show called
um welcome to sweetie pies which hit in
the fall of 2011.
um and we and we bought it from a friend
uh that i still friend with the vegan
credit pulitzer pilgrim
and the show was fundamentally about
this woman her name was miss robbie she
owned a soul food restaurant in st louis
missouri
it's great right up our alley you and i
would love it buzzer many times
and she had a son she was a backup
singer for
ike and tina turner she had a son
who fatherless son father left huge
issue in the african-american
community about boys who don't have
fathers was imprisoned and she's trying
to start a business and so we had a
reality show about this dynamic
and it exploded on the network and
the intention of it was that we were
going to put forth great imagery but
what we
learned upon intention and the lessons
we learned good
and bad was that we needed to have this
conversation with the community
and so we started having these
conversations and then the next show was
ian lavanzant
and it was about a yamaha being having
these conversations with men
and men and so what happened was as we
sort of found our footing and then we
were able to develop against it now i
look at the job that the network's done
you know over the past two years it's
tremendous i mean they've got this
amazing own your vote campaign and
tina perry who's the president of the
network now has done a miraculous job
they've got great dating shows and
they've created this beautiful very
narrow but extraordinarily deep niche
and that's why the network's successful
[Music]
is this the model used by
would you say all cable well like i mean
or just does anybody else like
yeah i mean i just i never heard it
described like that um
but i guess i look at it like there's no
health and
i mean like where's the health and
wellness otherwise yeah it's sort of
spread
you know depending upon where it goes
like if you go to like a food network
you know it's sort of a through line
through there you know um
so like for example we were part of the
discovery network hgtv
has a lot of wellness things that are in
there in that way
and a lot of the audiences that are
really focused on wellness will go find
it now in the digital world they'll find
it through whether it's their peloton or
their soul cycle bike
or wherever it may be um you know cable
is very challenged today with what's
going on with cord cutting
it's very very challenged i'm super
curious what your thoughts are and where
tv's going
oh yeah but i've got it yeah well i mean
i know you're surfing these days but
there's also roi that and like there's
how do you make money in surfing so yeah
television might be a part of that but
it is
it totally is the cable landscape is
such that you have
more and more choice and you know when i
was running own
we could see the oncoming of you know
what we'd call the streamers
netflix was coming at scale hulu was
getting that scale disney plus hadn't
launched yet
but you wake up today you think about
all the choices that you've got
it's everywhere and and so the
there's been a de-bundling of content
for the consumers so the consumers have
demanded choice
so danica has said i want to choose what
i want to watch i don't want to pay
you large cable company a lot of money
for 700 channels
i want this i want that so that's what
has happened
and so that creates pressure to the
established guard
the old cable networks creates
opportunity for the new guards which are
streamers
and if you're a content creator like we
are or even like how she is
oprah it provides opportunity for you to
tell very
focused niche stories in the way that is
good for your business so in our case
for the world surf league
we have a television show that we will
that will premiere next year on abc
that's a reality-based competition show
with seven men and seven women
shot at our surf ranch facility which
i'm inviting you to by the way in
california i would love to learn how to
survive let's go you and i will be there
before you know it that's why i asked
when you were leaving
next trip getting planned next trip
getting planned um but it you know
what they'll do is a compete for a spot
on our world tour
then we have documentaries about people
like kelly slater that we're taking out
we have um other shows that we're
creating about our sport and about
surfing
and i can now take advantage of this
debundling
and actually put our sport intentionally
with content telling the stories where i
want to tell them
all of that anchors back strategically
to the fact that we have a world tour
and we put on a professional sport so is
it going on cable or is it going on a
stream or you're able to sprinkle it
like well it depends on the show like
ultimate surfers on abc
so ultimate surfers yeah on the
broadcast here in the united states yep
yep
um the documentaries will be depending
upon what we did
for example we did a great uh
documentary 247 that hbo series uh with
kelly
uh we did that when he was going into
haleiwa the triple crown in hawaii last
year
actually won three emmys for kelly this
is good for him
it's good to be the king good to be
kelly slater he's pretty versatile he's
pretty he's pretty versatile
um but it would but i think that the
content landscape allows
that even in the audio space for like
yourself with pods
video pods and everything that's
happening it's really about from an
attention point of view
how do you want to convey your message
and how more focused you get
actually you can create more skill for
yourself in that way so
when i think about content strategy i
think about what do you want to say and
where do you want to put it
are they all going to live probably not
i think that
who's dying first well i'm not going to
give away my stock tips yet
but it's cable oh cable
cable yeah i mean i i i thought yeah
that too but i i mean i don't know i i
mean
yeah i just i think you're gonna see a
contraction for sure
of a lot of these cable networks you're
already starting to see them
start contracting down to a place where
that just you can't afford to run them
because
you know they're to a large part they're
subsidized by
subscribers right so if the subscribers
for your cable provider are trending
down
there's not the revenue coming in for
the cable network so that what happened
and then that's why you see
all of these other things there's i mean
think about it do you know what pluto is
have you heard of pluto
have you heard a file not even a planet
anymore no it's an app on your apple tv
that you can watch free television
really yes all of these things are
popping up
to give consumers more choice which is
puts more pressure on the old
establishment card
um and and again to survive
sort of this great unbundling of what's
happening you have to actually
focus on the consumer you're going to
think about it from your
choice it's like okay consumer has
choice where are they going to go
and then what's your value proposition
to the consumer so it's a better time
than ever
for a consumer a million percent
it's the best time to be a consumer if
you love content because they're all
vying for your eyeballs what do you
watch
what do i watch what's what what uh
platforms do you use to watch things i
am like i'm like the worst person that's
a question because i have
all of them i just finished naturally i
finished a great one
on hbo max called raised by wolves
it's a it's a real it's a sci-fi crazy
one ridley scott did it
it's really really good um and i'm
starting
starting jj abrams new one on hbo max
probably this weekend um and then what's
actually been more fun for me honestly
has been
that i'm now into season six from four
years ago of dance moms because my
daughters have discovered
i now realize where jojo siwa came from
i love the honesty
i love it i love it yeah so so that's
last night was dance moms for a while so
do you watch a lot of tv
not as much as you'd think yeah oh do
you feel like you have to say you watch
a lot of tv
i feel like there are a lot of people
you have to say that you do watch a lot
of content i'm like no i really don't i
like to read
because i don't watch i don't yeah i
don't watch the news anymore i don't
know i watch youtube videos that's my
most common thing that i
it's actually my morning news i stopped
watching the news and i started
like listening to like abraham hicks
like videos and
wayne dyer and you know all that super
soul sunday
like uh god the amount of super soul
sunday shorts that i've cried to
the letter from the dog god um stop it
yeah uh but yeah that's my news so i
don't i don't i don't but
i would imagine you feel like you have
to say you watch a lot of tv i do
a lot of people will always ask me that
a lot of people will be like what do you
watch and
what have you watched recently so i i
don't force myself to watch anything
why would are you would you say that you
watch less than you used to
for sure why for sure um
when it's a better time than ever
because for me
i don't need to i don't feel like i'm
obligated to
and um so you never wanted to maybe
yeah i mean it was like work for me okay
it was like i had
to watch like that show or this show so
for me
for me it's more of like hey if that
speaks to me
i want to get invested in it if it
doesn't speak to me i don't want to get
invested now
there are a lot of stuff that like for
our studio we have at the world surfly
we have a
studio that makes a lot of content i
watch a lot of that
because i need to note it or edit it or
like the notes for some of our shows
i'll do that
so but that to me is work that doesn't
sort of count i think the question's
more i think
discretionary it's like if i have an
hour i'm on the couch what am i doing
yeah yeah
so what do you normally do then so i
like to read
i attempt at least four or five
conversations with my daughters
um that gets you know how many actually
go on to being a conversation
not many it flies in and out based upon
this
and sometimes believe it or not it's
like well first of all i've been banned
from tick-tock i'm not allowed to have
tick-tock
yeah you're too yeah sorry you're too
old for too old for tick-tock but a lot
they'll throw it up they'll throw it up
and i'll just sit and watch them
and i'll just like voyeuristically see
what they're watching on tik tok and
it's sort of like
i honestly get plugged in to a really
important part of the culture
it's like you know and and and that this
gender and it's a and i
i looked at it now i flipped it i used
to be annoyed by it
like you know phone's down at dinner and
you talk to me and i want to hear about
your day versus
no no i need to flip it because it would
be better for me to
lean into that and be part of it hear
about it have them open up more and then
what happens as a part of that is that
a you get more of a connection with them
which i have and then
b i'm actually like looking at it going
oh okay surfing's a very young sport
anyway i mean a lot of some of our some
of our upcoming professional surfers the
same age as my daughter it's like
they're doing the same thing i was like
ah
now it's a little bit like i look at it
a little bit like market research i was
gonna say some insight it's insight
totally and it's funny like our mutual
friend scott you know bruschetta who
runs big machine
um often is godfather my oldest daughter
will call out of the blue and say okay
what are the girls listening to
and because they'd be they'll find stuff
on tick tock at the time musically or
youtube and
he would just call randomly just ask him
what they're listening to and again
when he was starting to do that it's
sort of like oh scott's much smarter
than i am i'm like oh okay i see what
he's doing you're very nice
i see i see what he's doing you both
have accomplished a tremendous amount
he's a good he's a good he's a good egg
huh what kind of books do you like to
read business books oh
yeah i mean i'm not a novelist you like
learning so either you're watching tv to
learn for work or you're reading to
learn i love to learn
so business books not not spiritual or
not
i have a couple that are spiritual but
my favorite spiritual book
is um mark nepo's i haven't even heard
of that so mark nepo
and um what he does is he has 365
passages each day you read a different
passage so you start the book for a year
there's short passages and they're very
intention laden oh i'll get you a copy
it's it's a good one and he was on he
was on a super soul sunday you can go
find it
um that was one of the best ones and
then i've done i've read a couple of
eckhart's books
you know which you know if you want to
talk to phd in ego he's the guy to talk
to
my favorite thing is listening to him
giggle he's first i don't know what you
think about that but it's like this
whole like you guys just don't get it
yep that's that part and it really is so
soothing
this voice it goes like this they talk
about the ego
and donna cut the ego come at you like
this you know he has a very
his it it almost puts me to sleep when
he talks
yeah i tried listening to an audiobook
and i like four minutes into it i was
like zonked out
it's those nights for you there's a
sleeping sleepless nights where you
can't get to sleep or you can't stay
asleep and just put that on i've
actually done that with wayne dyer
there's been some like you know life
crap that's going on and you're like i'm
like i just can't sleep right now and
i'll put a wayne dyer something wayne
dyer on and i love his voice too
it's not quite as uh not soothing not
quite as soothing as that cards but it's
a little more content and i keep
thinking
maybe i'm getting some subconscious
mental soap speaking to your soul
right directly into it yeah yeah he's
he's he's he does that but i'll do those
and then
uh the business books i just finished
read um uh read this book from netflix
who's the ceo of netflix
um interesting book about culture
because they have one of the most
interesting cultures that's out there
netflix does
um his name and it's called when you say
culture like
business culture okay you know about how
they run the company
they don't have expense reports they do
things like keeper tests
they pay people it's a very dog-eat-dog
culture and he talks about why he
approaches it that way an interesting
point of view what he did was
which i loved about this approach of the
book was
he said to this woman her name was aaron
i can't remember her last name she was a
harvard phd she wrote the book on
culture
but he's a big fan of hers and he said
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna write
a book
and then i want you he gave this woman
free access to talk to any employee she
wanted to in netflix to find out
if what he was saying about what he
thought the culture was was actually
true
and so he would make a point about like
the keeper test or something
and aaron would then have all these
different counterpoints
based upon what the employees were
actually saying so it's just very it was
such a
wonderful is it in sync it was it was
very much in sync and it was um
it was very transparent and what i
really appreciated about it was it was
like
i mean the you talk about surrendering
of the ego it's like here's a ceo of a
massively huge company
like hey i'm going to tell you what it
is go talk to anybody you want to
um it was it was really powerful so wow
so
books like that or biographies like you
know walter isaacson writes about steve
jobs i like stuff like that
so why did you take the job with world
surf league why
why great question perfect question um
so at the time a couple things were
going on at owen so we had turned the
network around
it was a an amazing turnaround literally
from
you know death's door now i mean the
network was losing a lot of money
um oprah was being drugged through the
press now in an amazingly terrible way
so that that was 2012. we turned it
around in 13
became profitable had a lot of success
with greenleaf and some of our other
shows
and then i was at the end of a deal of
my contract
and oprah had i had just done a deal
with her
and she started doing her apple
conversation so the apple conversation
started happening
and she was expanding beyond where the
cable network was
and we were in this really interesting
time back to the conversation about
consumer choice and cable and the
pressures and
the platform was only going to be able
to grow to a certain point and
the platform wasn't going to be able to
grow much beyond where it was
and so she was looking for other ways
and that's why what she was doing with
weight watchers and like with the tour
and these platforms and she's always
looking for new places to innovate how
to put her message out
that's what she did with the oprah show
that's what she did with own that's what
she did with oh magazine
and and we were at this place and my job
was was at the time the cable network
and i'd fall in love with surfing and i
loved surfing
and there was an interesting opportunity
she introduced me to the owner of the
world surf league a sort of on this
like a blind date kind of thing like you
should meet this guy the universe
it it was and i didn't know who it was
she goes i'm on a boat
with a guy that we were talking surfing
you got to talk to my president ceo he
that's all he does is talk about surfing
but i'm like okay cool so i'm emailing
this guy
i have no idea who it is like what board
do you like
you know this that and and i'm like
who is this guy i have no idea and i
said what are you doing surfing i have
no clue because well i own the world
surf league and then i called oprah and
she goes i told you it was a good hookup
i'm like holy cow
so dirk and i developed a relationship
and one thing led to another and he said
hey
we're thinking about starting a studio
and the time felt right we'd turn the
network around
i said this would be fun i'd be able to
just focus on content
not that i was going to retire but it
was sort of like
this would be a fun challenge to build a
studio around surfing leverage
everything i've learned in tv
and just do it around surfing my passion
and so
you know um i walked into her office
one afternoon and she was there and uh
said you have a minute i go yeah so we
shut the door we had this little joke
was like oh it's a door closer i go it's
a door closer and it's only gonna take a
minute it's gonna close the door
and i sat down and i said uh it's time
and she had no idea what i was saying
she goes it's time i go it's time she
goes
it's time and i told her did she get it
when she said
it's time okay got it it took her the
second okay she got it
and uh and she smiled and she was
she was she lit up and she's like this
is
a beautiful moment for you oh yeah it
was great it was
exactly what you would imagine her to
say and then she walked around the desk
gave me a big hug
and she said she goes it's divine this
is what the way it's supposed to be
and um somebody here oprah's greatest
you know no i mean she is danica she
really is
and then i'm there for a year and then a
year after that i'm now the ceo
so then it leads to me to kind of what
i'm what i'm curious about
and that's what you think your purpose
is um
what do i think my purpose is
i think it's evolved you know i think
my purpose and i i'll give you
a couple of different answers and they
probably intersect
um i love trying to
find ways to bring out the best in other
people i i try to be
a very selfless person um i try to
focus a lot on my daughters because you
know i
they're throughout the door in three
years and you know
the time with them is shrinking and you
know i meant to sound like i come back
yeah i promise
i went live with my parents this summer
for three months they come back
yeah well it's one but you're off the
payroll i i i'm worried
you're definitely you're definitely off
the payroll right um
but you know so i think it's you know
from that perspective so
for me it's like i like seeing other
people achieve things they didn't think
was possible
um i like i like having people believe
in things that are bigger than
themselves
you know i look back at uh when i
reflect back
take surfing out of it but all the
surfing where the wsl is is actually
a very interesting inflection points the
same way but own
was a complete you know was was a
problem
you know when i was running xm it was a
startup no one thought we ever could get
people to pay for radio and we did
um and when we built that company it was
the same way and then all the radio
stations and all the country stuff they
were all like
you can't go at 23 to move to seattle
and be this you can't do
and so a lot of my pathology in my life
had been you can't you can't you can't
you can't you can't and what i realized
was i was proving something to myself
but then what i actually realized that
the joy came from actually watching
other people see
things that they can't see having them
believe in the fact that we could do
this and believe in the fact that we
were going to do this and then seeing
that happen was like
more fulfilling to me than anything else
and so
i i love i like that i like trying to be
the connector the facilitator
i never think i'm the smartest person in
the room i believe everybody else is
smarter
i try to be the one that sort of like
brings it together
and then allows the alchemy alchemist to
happen
and i try to do that with my family also
a great book it's a great book too
colo not a bad one yeah so then how are
you trying to use
surfing as the medium to
fulfill this purpose for myself yeah
well or are you i am actually um
for i think on two different paths i
think for
for me personally um
it is about can i take what i've learned
in my professional career
and apply that to something
extraordinarily foreign
you know yep and and it's like what an
interesting challenge
you know it's sort of spirituality
surfing country radio
chuck the duck xm satellite radio okay
i can take all that and can i put this
into a surfing modality
interesting challenge um and i think
that
a a higher altitude challenge for me
with the company is trying to see
or convey beyond just the sheer talent
that we have of our surfers and
all that we do from professional side
that this
sport global sport that happens around
the planet
actually the people who participate in
it the participatory not just the
athletes but the participants
do it for reasons that sometimes they
can't see themselves but there's
something beyond it
and i think it's a lofty challenge and a
goal for me to help people
understand that and see that because i
look at a sport that took
a kid from oklahoma that couldn't swim
to do what i've been able to do
it shifted me and i'm a really good
example of what i think that sport can
do and i see a lot of people who
speak in terms that they can't they
don't have the nomenclature they don't
have the framework the thinking the
experience the way to articulate it
the way that i can and the only reason
why i can articulate i spent 10 years
next to somebody that taught me how to
articulate it
so i was able to fuse the two things
together and
for me i think that that is a an amazing
way to sort of connect
two really really important worlds
passion over on one side
and purpose on the other and you know i
say oftentimes
for me it's like i i feel so blessed to
have an opportunity right now and it
won't last forever
to marry my passion and purpose it's
like you know you've got profession
passion and purpose you can bring this
all together
it's hard it's really really hard to do
that and i'm very very lucky to do it
so i try to stay very present with that
what um
that's there's so much integrity there
um that's brave right because it could
be probably easy to take shortcuts and
just like you know how to
totally make something big or make money
or or just go surfing right but then to
put them together
um is a venture
so you want to inspire people to you
know
be able to believe in something beyond
to do more to accomplish more so
how how am i how are you going to do
that what what am i going to
what what can i take away if i if i
watch and where
so i'll watch it on abc yeah you're
watching for there ultimate surfer comes
out
at the beginning of the year in 2021 and
then there's going to be some
documentaries documentaries or real
like we'll be surfing and we'll be
surfing hawaii you know at the end of
the year
for our the tour will come back yeah and
we have our big wave tour to come back
um you know and part of it is sequential
you know so one of the things i learned
in content
in in the in the own space was a term
that i used to always talk about called
hide the spinach
i hide the spinach um well the smoothie
still turns green so you gotta use a
colored cup
so it's true so make it black right yeah
that you know doing doing super soul
sunday
your favorite show has a very narrow
audience because it's very
focused on that a broader audience was
watching
like the oprah show right right so
what oprah was ingenious doing was
having people
using a star like yourself to come sit
on the show and have a conversation
because people wanted to hear about you
and your racing career and the first
woman to do this and oh my god most
successful indy card right
all that people like oh danica and then
what she'd do is she'd get people
to the television and then she'd have a
conversation about spirituality
and she'd thread it through right okay
so
that's that to me is what i refer to as
hiding spinach and so
when we can do things in our broadcast
about a program like rising tides about
how we get
young kids and women and girls to start
learning about the surf or talk stories
about indigenous people
talk about what's happening with very
you know very
huge issues in our country with social
justice or
in australia with you know with the you
know what's happening in terms of
the stolen generation or south africa
with apartheid or whatever it may be
that if i have a platform of surfers i
can tell these stories through there and
so how do we figure out a way
to elevate the narrative
in a way that brings it to light while
you at the same time are watching kelly
slater out of a barrel at jbay
and take advantage of it so you know it
that's a heavy lift it's a hard thing
you have to be very intentional about it
but it's it's um
you know higher that's the higher
vibration that i'm trying to
i literally i mean like this really
resonates with me i don't know if it
will with you
but you are completely paralleling
you going surfing it is entertaining
lessons
you are creating entertaining lessons
entertaining lessons i got a lot of time
on my hands you need me for anything
that's what i know i'm trying to get you
to go to the surf wrench okay we start
there
start the surface some entertaining
lessons and then we see where it goes
from there
that's a perfect place for us to start
what a cool venture
i'm so happy for you and it's i don't
know how you feel but it's it's there's
there's a magic in the passion well
that's the fuel
for for anyone i hope certainly for me
that the passion
of what i'm doing for me makes it
that's what drives me because it's hard
i mean it
there i mean i have awful days like we
all do
you know and you know i always i'm like
okay well why am i doing this
you know it's certainly through this
pandemic i've asked that question
a lot and that's again it's the
self-doubt it's all this
it's the struggle we all have and to not
be honest about it is not being
authentic but it's like you know
i have bad days just like everybody else
and you asked if i cried so yeah there's
just days it's like it's just
too hard it's just hard
that's actually one la one one final
thought i want you to unpack because i
think this is really um
a powerful concept that i have felt like
has played into my life but
i think it resonates because i've read
it
from you and that's the word belief
believing
believing like i don't i mean there's
it's like
simple to just say i believe it's gonna
happen but can you
can you try and explain believing
in a way that will help someone know how
to
for me when i say i believe we're going
to do something
um it is a statement of
knowing that through the fiber of my
body there's not a doubt
and you know i
it's all you know when you get the
chicken skin sometimes you know when you
get the little ah hot things and you get
the little twitches
you know and their ways that just sort
of happen for me
it's like when i start talking i'm very
aware
that oh i just got it it just came to me
it looked like an angel whisperer or
things like that
that's when i know i'm on the right
track and that's when i know that
there's something higher that is like
keep going keep going so for me when i'm
saying i'm believing
i have done the work of underturning all
the rocks
when when you are so confident and
you you believe in your core that that
is going to absolutely happen
an amazing thing happens you know what
happens to everybody else around you
they believe you and then they have
confidence
and that comes with a heavy backpack of
a burden it comes with a heavy backpack
of like okay i feel the weight
you know i've now put that backpack on
my back because i'm the one saying it
um but if you've got the right team of
people and you have the right support
you have the right partners
then then that belief becomes a power
and then so you flip it so i i think the
way i'd have people try to understand
the power of belief
is that there is not an ounce of doubt
in your mind
and even there is validation however you
choose to see it or feel it or
experience it
that reaffirms what that belief is so
that's how i
that's that's why when i when i get on
my thing of like this is what we're
going to do
what if somebody can't get there like if
i said i believe i can dunk a basketball
yeah
i believe it yep clearly i don't i'm
five foot one and a half like i ain't
gonna dunk a basketball ever in my life
but i do actually believe because i'm a
really esoteric thinker
that if i truly actually believed it to
my core i actually think i could
but there's no way because i'm i i
believe in
reality too much as it's presented um so
what happens then
if because it's people get stuck
they get stuck so what happens if you
can't get there you can't believe what
you need to believe
to be successful or to achieve what you
want i think you want
so let's take your example for a second
so you want to dunk a basketball
but you said you believe you can i'm
gonna tell you that you can and i'm
gonna so what we're gonna do is we're
actually going to reframe
the statement of what you believe in you
can't dunk a 10-foot rim basketball
but if i put a 5-foot rim over here you
could dunk it so have you now actually
dunked it
yes so you're a good boss huh
you're a good boss so to me it's about
framing you know the sort of question
the right way
and if somebody is stuck you know
the the energy flow being stuck or
the connection being stuck needs to be
viewed
as a signal that you're just on a wrong
road so just choose a different road
so much easier said than done though it
is but that but that is the
that's the work that i think that that
people
you know if someone were to ask me like
you and be like how do you do it it's
like okay so
you know one of the things we used to
always practice a lot was that this term
doubt means don't
and it's really really hard but in
business i do it
a lot i'm not very good in my personal
life
but we cut from the same cloth then i'm
really good at business i'm good at
letting go and doing things and
relationships i'm like ah
yeah exactly without me i'm really you
know i got a lot of work that's the
second podcast there's a lot of work on
that one
but yeah part two part two uh but the
doubt but
when you get when you get a doubt or you
get that
doubt for me just say doubt means don't
and then when you start talking about
things you believe in until you don't
have those feelings then you're like
okay
that i can believe then so even if cause
there's
one thing about being a good boss and
encouraging people and getting me to
dunk a five-foot poop
right i get it and that's honestly
because it's just a shift in mindset a
perception change
a language change the universe doesn't
know the difference whether it was five
or ten feet
um but all of a sudden there's a shift
in energy there
um so now what if you're a boss what if
it's your company what if it's your
your job to say every
we're all gonna dunk a basketball all
every single one of you but you're like
god i know they can't you know i know
they're
so what happens if you're in that stuck
spot
and you're the boss
[Music]
even harder to run away right because
you're a boss you're probably getting
paid well you're secure
like what do you what would you say to
that person who's
who's stuck there that's like successful
by
you know cultural standards but like
emotionally spiritually and
energetically
poor as hell well i think there's a
question attached to that too so we'll
ask the second question we'll answer
that one so that i think there's a
you know if you're the boss and you're
saying that you know it's not true
you actually have an ego dilemma it's
coming back to your ego thing
right circle full circle now we're to
full circle right
now you're at your ego and it's sort of
like okay now how do you want to be
viewed in this moment
and so for me it's like in that moment
what i would say to people is
you know be humble be transparent and be
honest
and then and don't bury the lead don't
qualify it with a comma
don't don't just you know put everybody
on your zoom screen and be like okay so
you know what
no one's dunking a basketball let's get
honest about let's get very real about
that
but here's what i believe we can do and
so
what by doing that what happens is you
actually become
i think in my opinion more powerful
owning the mistake
owning the narrative owning your own
truth about the matter
and speaking that then the people they
go
okay all right all right so here's what
we're gonna do
and then you reframe it yourself but
sometimes just
blind faith for blind faith's sake
actually is the worst thing for a
company or a culture and
a relationship you know yep you know um
and so i've lived that and at a certain
point you just gotta
as we call the ball and be like yep no
and so
in this case in a business framing for
me it's like
we're not gonna be able to start the
tour it's over
or i made a mistake here's how we're
gonna fix it
i own it let's move on i think everybody
is so afraid of saying that especially
leaders
and i would say especially young leader
this was a hard lesson for me as a young
executive
was was learning to own that
it's like standing in front of a company
and say you made a mistake
but the sooner you understand that that
actually is a powerful thing for you
the more liberating you feel you become
a better leader because you know it's
like hey if i screw it up i'm just gonna
tell you screw it up and we're gonna
keep going
it's fine i am excited like i was
i was at this like meditation circle the
other night and you know it's a bunch of
hippies and i'm like i can't wait to see
the culture and the future of the world
when all these little
hippie kids grow up you know and this
sort of trans
transition um culturally but
so in the same exact vein i can't wait
to see
what happens with business and content
and the integrity behind it
that someone like you is leading the way
with because i think
gone are the days and i think 2020 is
dissolving so much of this where
you know we can sort of uh
have poor intentions and poor uh ethics
and um not be in our heart space and in
our own integrity and our own truth
and um expect to have any kind of
support or longevity or belief because
i think we're all getting energetically
a lot more educated and
inclined and that's why you're going to
blow up
surfing and i'm going to probably make
the league and you're oh for sure
i mean you're gonna teach me everything
i need to know that's right don't worry
i got you listen i started i started
when i was older than what you are now
so you gotta you gotta fart you got a
big future ahead of you
thank you thank you this has been fun
thank you so much thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button